[Musique]
puis avait dit bonjour bonjour est ce
que le président d'un département qui
comprend la présidente de l'assemblée
nationale et le président du sénat est
un président département fier oui parce
que c'est historique les à ma
connaissance dans aucun département de
france
cette configuration se trouvait alors on
avait déjà eu des premiers ministres des
présidents de groupe on en a d'ailleurs
à nouveau un président nouveau parfum
une plus exactement mais à deux
présidents des deux assemblées
délibérantes
unique unique en yvelines unique en
france alors voir venir un petit peu sur
les résultats des élections légistatives
d'abord dans ce département
vous avez commenté ce résultat en dix
ans aux faux on voit bien que
l'électorat bhl la droite traditionnelle
à voter pour les candidats macro nist en
grande partie et vous même au moment de
la désignation des candidats de l erp
vous avez dit bon je vais suivre les
consignes de mon mouvement mais on
sentait que vous auriez préféré
peut-être que passé déjà un accord avec
la majorité présidentielle
est ce que vous pensez vous avez raté
peut-être enfin en silence et consignes
de l'air vous avez raté peut-être une
occasion de sauver une ou deux
circonscriptions très probablement oui
c'est comme ça ensuite
les partis politiques ont besoin de
discipline et la démocratie a besoin de
partis politiques que ce que nos
concitoyens ne comprennent pas toujours
s'il leur rôle est d inscrire dans la
constitution c'est l'article 4 ils
concourent à l'expression du suffrage
universel
donc mon parti ne le souhaitez pas donc
j'ai respecté les consignes mais j'étais
partisan effectivement d'une négociation
comme on l'avait eu dans le département
des yvelines moment des élections
départementales
puisque nous sommes une majorité
plurielle et ça nous a permis non
seulement de remporter un grand succès
mais c'est pas ça l'important mais de
bien montrer qu'il y avait une
communauté de vues pour gérer une grande
collectivité et c'était
pour bien gérer une grande collectivité
c'était ça pour moi l'essentiel et je
suis toujours mais ça sera peut-être une
question plus tard partisans de toutes
façons de la discussion on ne peut pas
laisser la france partir à vau l'eau la
situation est d'une extrême gravité
c'est pas si nos concitoyens en sont
bien conscients et que sans aller
jusqu'à l'union nationale je pense qu'il
faut qu'il y ait une majorité et une
opposition mais que cette opposition
doit être responsable enfin du moins ce
qui concerne les républicains c'est à
dire ma formation politique lors des
fouilles en règle tout à l'heure sur le
plan de la politique nationale mais
c'est vrai que les il ya deux
circonscriptions justement où il ya il y
avait deux sortants les deux sortants et
l'ère philippe benassaya et
l'a8 de la 11e à la 8e circonscription
qui sont allés alain denis pesce
s'il y avait peut-être une candidature
commune pour c'est peut-être que l'élu
ps n'aurait peut-être pas remporter ces
élections font en tout cas il y avait
une chose qu'elles ne remontent pas
probablement probablement on peut jamais
réécrire le match
mais très probablement après c'est vrai
que dans ces deux circonscriptions le
résultat de m'a pas surpris ce sont les
deux circonscriptions qui historiquement
sont de gauche et que par cette grande
alliance de la gauche appelait nubes
donc il prononçait le s donc lui pour
son comble
je suis originaire du gers donc on a
l'habitude wipro tcs
et donc la nuque mais ce qui a créé une
dynamique de gauche a fort logiquement
récupérer les deux circonscriptions qui
sont le plus à gauche dans notre
histoire
depuis que ces circonscriptions existe
donc depuis 1988
chaque fois qu'il ya une poussée de
gauche ces deux circonscriptions étaient
à gauche oui elles suivent aussi souvent
les tendances nationales dans ce petit
peu de ça c'était largement une élection
nationale et les les facteurs locaux
pèsent de moins en moins dans les
élections nationales oui c'est de
réduire les deux circonscriptions voilà
qui sont le bruit c'est logique c'est
logique il n'y a rien de sûr produits ce
qui est ce qui est assez intéressant
c'est que ce sont aussi des
circonscriptions de laquelle il ya des
quartiers de la politique de la ville
que ce soit à trappes s'assoit à mantes
la jolie montre la ville et on voit que
dans ces quartiers les corps des
personnes au fait des gros scores
pour se rattrape plus de 60% à monte
est ce que la droite ou la droite et des
maquereaux nist ont raté quelque chose
dans cette
campagne nous à cette élection
oui autrement on n'aurait pas perdu dans
des proportions pareil mais là aussi à
une certaine logique les quartiers
d'habitat populaire traditionnellement
votre plutôt à gauche
ce sont des sociologies
dont l'orientation à gauche et très
anciennes donc il ya sans doute une
grande cohérence j'ajouterai un deuxième
aspect c'est que il ya beaucoup de
musulmans dans ces quartiers alors on
parle tout de suite de votre
communautaires etc je me méfie de deux
de ses phrases stigmatisante mais c'est
vrai que
les candidats du ps ont donné le
sentiment
de ne pas être simplement préoccupés par
la question de l'identité religieuse et
que nous avons aujourd'hui en france ce
lent poison qui à mon avis est mauvais
pour la société française de ce que
j'appelle moi l'identitarisme l'identité
française elle est difficile à définir
parce qu'elle est multiple elle est
diverse elle est varié elle s'est
construite
depuis des siècles et des siècles pour
pas dire plus d'un millénaire donc
ça très probablement aussi joué dans le
vote je connais des gens de confession
musulmane qui sont pas du tout de gauche
encore moins d'extrême gauche mais qui
ont voté ni baisse parce qu'ils avaient
le sentiment qu'ils pouvaient ainsi
faire passer un message
anti islamophobie des guerres c'est
intéressant parce que souvent des
quartiers où il ya une abstention assez
forte et là on a noté même entre les
deux tours une mobilisation
assez importante de ces quartiers
une mobilisation qui a été favorable à
la nuque est probablement très favorable
ans il y avait aussi un autre aspect de
ce que j'ai pu entendre
il ya eu aussi une mobilisation très
anti ministre de l'intérieur présenti
darmanin 13 antipolis après les
évènements du stade de france alors pas
forcément toujours pour les mêmes
raisons mais
le sentiment dans ces quartiers que ça
cet homme des grands sujets quand même à
mon avis de la république dans ces
quartiers la police est perçue de façon
exclusivement négative et donc je pense
qu'il ya un travail considérable à faire
de la police des élus aussi et de l'état
pour faire que la police apparaissent
pour ce qu'elle est un pilier de la
république
on a absolument besoin de police celle
qui fait respecter la loi
et pour ce faire pense qu'il le serait
pas inutile de d'essayer de faire un
rapprochement entre les habitants de ces
quartiers et les policiers
parce que donc on a vu à l'occasion de
cette élection que le foutoir du stade
de france et ce qui est apparu comme la
mauvaise foi du ministre de l'intérieur
eh bien ça ça a créé un espèce depuis
une espèce de dynamique et de dynamique
mobilisatrice
vous êtes beaucoup intéressé
est
ce que au fond il n'y a pas eu une
erreur justement peut-être en insistant
sur cette identité rythme de la droite
de laisser aux faux ses quartiers à la
gauche
s'est vérifié l'udc est plus compliqué
que ça c'est un peu plus compliqué que
ça mais alors moi je suis vraiment
convaincu qu'
il faut que ça fait partie de mon avis
de la réforme
ce positionnement exact ailleurs réforme
que les républicains doivent faire c'est
de deux de se mettre au clair sur un
certain nombre de points de doctrine
et en particulier il faut clarifier ses
affaires d'identité
et de dimension religieuse nous sommes
une république laïque la droite
historiquement la droite légitimiste
était hostile à la loi de séparation de
l'église et de l'état de 1905
aujourd'hui la droite est entièrement
rallier à cette vision laïque de la
société donc ils font tirer quand même
clairement les enseignements et bien
réfléchir posément calmement même si ce
sont des sujets un peu explosif et des
sujets pas simple mais avec
une approche
humaniste je pense que on doit pouvoir
aborder ces sujets et mettre au clair
nos doctrines pour comprendre bien que
encore une fois la france a de multiples
identités et qu'avec l'histoire ces
identités certaines se renforce d'autres
s'affaiblissent la france est encore
vivant et tout ça est tout à fait normal
et pas confondre toujours les musulmans
et islamistes exactement oui aujourd'hui
et puis alors c'est vrai que les
questions migratoires sont des questions
dont on a finalement assez peu parlé
dans la campagne alors qu'elles sont
très importantes comment faire la
position qui consiste à dire il faut
contrôler nos frontières c'est oui il
faudrait que le soleil se lève à l'ouest
et se couche à l'est
c'est impossible de mettre un policier
tous les tous les maîtres aux frontières
donc pourquoi pourquoi cette immigration
et comment peut-on faire pour que cette
immigration ne soit pas
ce set cette créatrice d'injustice de
douleurs de deux drames humains de part
et d'autre je suis totalement convaincu
que quelles que soient les difficultés
économiques que nous puissions
rencontrer si nous ne sommes pas
capables d'aider au développement des
parties du monde d'où vient cette
immigration économique
et bientôt climatique
on pourra pas l'empêcher
alors on va revenir aux autres
circonscriptions les dix
circonscriptions dans laquelle il ya des
des élus ou maquereau 10 to model enfin
qui ont des circonscriptions
relativement de droit afin qu'ils sont
de droite traditionnellement
relativement bourgeoise est ce que
justement ça te dit quelque chose du
maquereau 10 mhz le fait qu'il soit élu
dans ses rangs ce que je jouais ce que
vaut le mercredi franchement pas un peu
plus à droite qu'à gauche quoi
vous qui êtes très jeune vous n'avez
retenu rené rémond qui avait des
endroits qui avait défini les trois
droits absolus la droite légitimiste la
droite bonapartiste et la droite aura
lieu à nice tu dans les yvelines
l'électorat de droite est largement
orléaniste c'est à dire c'est une droite
libérale en matière économique est
plutôt européenne assez ouverte sur les
questions sociétales et c'est la
majorité de la droite et c'est vrai que
cet électorat là se retrouvent plus dans
mes manuels macron qu' il ne s'est
retrouvé dans valérie pécresse
et que ce mouvement avaient déjà été
entamés
au moment des précédentes élections
législatives de 2010 est donc hors ias
s'est largement liée à la personnalité
des manuels macron donc ça n'est pas
définitif puisque comme chacun le sait
le président macro entame son second et
dernier mandat
c'est désormais la règle
constitutionnelle donc je pense que les
choses reviendront après les les les
rivières respectives de la gauche et de
la droite regagneront leur lit mais en
l'état actuel oui il ya eu septe cette
droite orléaniste qui s'est retrouvé
dans ce président
dont la gauche
l'accusent d'être trop à droite mais bon
ça c'est voilà c'est peut-être donc pas
totalement faux avec une nouveauté quand
même aussi dans la 9e circonscription et
notamment dans le les petites communes
rurales la force du rassemblement
national avec pour la première fois nous
faut un candidat sur le national au
deuxième tour je suis pas sûr que ça
soit pour la première fois je suis même
certain du contrat puisque la première
fois que j'ai été élu ad il était en
1993 de sa dalle de verre patrice elle
j'avais été élu non pas dans une
triangulaire je l'étais de leurs 1993
face à un candidat front national dans
la 8e circonscription des yvelines on a
déjà une ou des élections
départementales des élections même
parfois municipal où on était face au
front national au deuxième tour donc ça
n'est pas nouveau
ce qui est nouveau c'est l'ampleur c'est
l'ampleur alors pas dans les yvelines
nous avons échappé à un député front
national mais
en france on se retrouve avec un groupe
pour la première fois de notre histoire
le groupe front national et plus
puissant que le groupe de ma propre
famille politique donc ça nous interroge
on ne peut pas faire comme si c'était
pas passer quelque chose on a vraiment
intérêt à changer à mettre au clair je
l'évoqué tout à l'heure notre position
sur un certain nombre de sujets pour les
assumer très clairement et puis on a
sans doute aussi intérêt à changer les
visages qui incarne ses idées ben
justement il ya eu des nouveaux visages
karl olive alors qu'il vient députés qui
votent au vice-président vous possédez
départemental charles rodwell qui est un
jeune c'est bien ce renouvellement
justement des figures politiques hauts
fourneaux il faut pas sombrer dans le
jeunisme mais il faut être bien lucide
sur le fait que le renouvellement est
nécessaire tout corps social a besoin de
se renouveler et donc les élus eux mêmes
alors vous avez dit là au soir du
premier tour au fond qui a vu un échec
ce qui est vrai pour l aie aie aie et
que vous assumerez la présidence de
votre fédération jusqu'à la désignation
du nouveau président de l ordre national
sa veux dire
ça a été interprété parfois comme l'idée
que vous alliez ses 17 présences de
l'air je souhaite ne pas
poursuivre ma mission parce que je
considère qu'il faut justement des
visages nouveaux je ne peux pas dire
qu'il faut des visages nouveaux et ne
pas m'impliquer
dans cette rénovation là il impliqué
personnellement donc oui je pense qu'il
faut un nouveau président
de l air qui viendra avec d'autres idées
et qui sera en harmonie avec le nouveau
président donc tout ça doit se passer ça
n'est pas une désertion
tout ça doit se passer comme
un passage de flambeau un passage de
témoin alors la politique nationale
c'est vrai qu'on voit que l air est un
peu divisé entre il ya les députés qui
disent non on ne pactisera pas avec avec
le pouvoir en place et puis un certain
nombre d'élus qui disent au contraire
ben non on va pas laisser se propager
une crise qui pourrait être une crise
institutionnelle et ça c'est intéressant
parce que au fond si on regarde ceux qui
sont plutôt contre la participation sont
les députés des élus nationaux ceux qui
sont plutôt pour un accord possible ce
sont comme vous des présidents de région
des mers est ce qui est pas au fond une
coupure de la politique justement entre
ceux qui exercent pour locales et les
autres qui sont peut-être un peu plus
coupés des réalités
votre remarque est extrêmement juste
patrice et je pense que tant que nous ne
reviendrons pas sur cette mauvaise loi
de suppression du cumul des mandats
douze jours
une divergence croissante entre les élus
nationaux et les élus locaux alors
qu'ils procèdent normalement de la même
sanctification du suffrage universel et
donc il y en a pas une catégorie qui a
raison une catégorie 14 et lorsque on
peut cumuler les deux gt cumulards ce
mot si vilain ça permet effectivement de
nourrir son travail national de son
expérience locale et de pouvoir prendre
des décisions nationales qui vont
profiter à l'échelon local donc l'arrêt
de deux ça a été un très mauvais coup
porté à la république et au
fonctionnement de l'état de l'état
républicain donc bon c'est comme ça
j'espère encore une fois qu'on y
reviendra toujours est il que oui
localement nous sommes habitués à passer
des contrôles qui ne sont pas les
compromissions selon l'expression
désormais à la mode
heureusement qu'on travaille ensemble en
république
si on ne travaille pas ensemble si on
est émis les uns des autres c'est la
guerre civile et cet esprit de guerre
civile est très dangereux très dangereux
pour le pays surtout alors que les
périls les périls intérieur les périls
extérieurs n'ont jamais non jamais été
aussi aussi fort donc oui bien sûr il
faut je plaide pour cette collaboration
il faut alors le mot opus collaboration
et puis il était très négativement
mais il faut il faut travailler ensemble
après ma doctrine c'est pas de
participation
collaboration compromis mais pas
participation de 100 sur certains objets
rares à ne pas envoyer l'image de jean
selon l'expression trivial qui vont à la
gamelle je trouve que ces débauchages
individuels sont une très mauvaise chose
et le camp majoritaire a eu tort de
procéder à ces tentatives ou à ses
succès d'ailleurs de débauchage
individuel parce que ça ne donne pas une
bonne image de la politique ça renvoie
encore nos concitoyens à ce sentiment
que la politique c'est un truc pas bien
pas propre mais il faut bien entendu un
travail en commun il faut qu'ils aient
des
vote des projets de loi gouvernementaux
il faut que le gouvernement accepte des
propositions de loi venant du groupe et
l'air il faut qu'au produit on s'était
jean françois copé mon ami jean françois
copé qui avait inventé ce terme de
coproduction législative
à une autre époque puisqu'il y avait une
majorité présidentielle qui
correspondait peu ou prou à la majorité
parlementaire mais jean françois copé
avait voulu cette coproduction dix ans
la cinquième république
ne peut pas durablement être un système
où le chef décide de tout c'était pas du
tout la vision du général de gaulle
lorsqu'il crée 7/5 7/5 république il
faut que le pouvoir lui même le soir à
l'heure de jeu par un seul président ont
commencé la propose et il faut
naturellement un certain équilibre entre
les pouvoirs présidentiels et
législatifs entre l'exécutif et le
législatif
alors on parle beaucoup de crises
institutionnelles nous fait qu'il y ait
pas de majorité absolue à l'assemblée
nationale mais est-ce que c'est aussi
grave que que les commentaires le disait
ce que justement il faut pas prendre une
une pratique politique et celle pas du
compromis de la négociation est ce que
c'est si grave que ça doit prendre ça au
final on a l'impression que non et oui
non ce n'est pas si grave oui il faut
apprendre cette culture du compromis la
discussion
on est plus intelligent à deux tout seul
ce qui serait grave c'est en effet comme
on lisait dans un moment où les
difficultés la guerre les difficultés
économiques qui aide financière pour les
deux premières et dick s'accumulent
exact d'où bloquer quoi on peut pas se
permettre de recommencer une campagne
dans la campagne
il faut que le pays avance il faut
prendre des décisions
qui sont parfois compliquées douloureuse
le temps de la démagogie n'est plus
possible il ya plus d'argent donc on
peut pas distribuer ce qu'on n'a pas et
il va y avoir la questionnette va se
poser vous avez parlé de toutes les
crises y en a une ou ticket qui est
l'ultime c'est la crise sociale
je travaille sur la question des charges
payées par les locataires en logement
social
avec l'explosion des coûts de l'énergie
je ne sais pas comment on va faire les
gens les plus modestes je sais pas
comment ils vont réussir à payer ces
augmentations de charges vous avez une
augmentation du coût de l'énergie qui
est de plus de 100%
les sociétés ou les offices qui
détiennent des logements sociaux sont
incapables d'absorber ce choc
sans la répercuter sur les locataires et
les locataires sont les plus fragiles et
les plus pauvres ils ont déjà du mal à
payer les charges telles qu'elles
existent comment va-t-on faire comme
qu'elle avait une réponse dans nos
dépenses non je n'ai pas de réponse et
les réponses que nous avons ne sont que
des réponses de moyen terme parce qu'il
faut effectivement changé notre façon
les remercie de mon chemin c'était alors
peut-être qu'il va falloir le faire à
court terme peut-être qu'une des
solutions va être c'est pas une annonce
un mais c'est une piste de baisser la
température dans les appartements
peut-être qu'il va falloir qu'on
s'habitue lorsqu'on rentre chez nous le
soir a passé un pull
est ce qu'on va pouvoir continuer à
éclairer
nos villes et nos villages toute la nuit
et
je ne sais pas je n'ai pas les réponses
que je sais c'est que l'explosion c'est
hallucinant on n'a jamais connu ça
l'explosion des coûts de l'énergie va
pas être sans conséquences sur notre vie
quotidienne puisque des maisons on va
terminer on voit revenir à quelque chose
de plus au calme et que vous êtes du
hacker et il ya eu une élection
municipale
montrent la jolie il y avait la
démission du maire a fait le cogner qui
avait été mis en minorité par son
conseil municipal vous savez vous
soutenu un autre candidat qui était
monsieur santini
finalement aura falconi a été
réélu au 1er tour vous avez dit
l'électeur a toujours raison mais en
santé que il avait raison on va faire ça
vous plaît un peu bah oui puisque
j'étais même sur la glace brisée sur les
sentiers donc
quelle conclusion vous avez tiré de cet
épisode j'ai un peu tôt pour tirer des
conclusions définitives
d'abord la première conclusion c'est que
je n'ai pas su - expliquer pourquoi
je cognais n'était pas adapté à gérer la
ville demande alors que il avait été mis
en place par une majorité dont je
faisais partie donc c'est d'abord un
défaut de communication de pédagogie
donc c'est une faute personnelle
ensuite
ça n'a fait que confirmer ce que je
pensais déjà depuis un certain temps
c'est que il ya un moment où le
personnel politique doit se renouveler
c'est un phénomène naturel et ce moment
et est arrivé voilà donc c'est la vie
c'est ainsi ça n'est pas toujours
plaisant mais il faut savoir bien
entendu l'accepter donc je que je crains
beaucoup c'est que ayant découvert moi
même les défauts qui de mon point de vue
robin est inapte pardon à la fonction ne
se cognait je crains que les mantais
c'est est ce que mon post ils nous
attendaient je crains qu'ils mentent
elles découvrent aussi car je ne pense
pas m'être trompé sur ce sujet je serais
très heureux si je me suis trompé sur ce
sujet parce que j'ai aimé passionnément
être maire de man 7 mais lille est
importante pour moi et si les électeurs
se sont trompés comme je le crains ça
sera douloureux et donc ça sera
extrêmement douloureux pour moi aussi et
donc très contre al impression que vous
regardez un peu la vie politique avec du
recul maintenant
je suis plus proche de la sortie que
l'entrée pour faire beau cher patrice
c'est la vie ça aussi ce que j'ai appris
[Musique]
de la vie politique
me donne toujours autant envie
mais ce que je vois qu'elle ait deux
juges
parfois un peu tu as cette envie c'est
vrai parce que d'abord la
judiciarisation
la violence la violence la
multiplication aussi des des embûches
dès qu'on a un projet et ça sera à mon
avis de la crise de la démocratie locale
la prochaine crise de la démocratie
locale elle est liée au fait que lorsque
vous êtes élu
le temps démocratique de 6 on est
incompatible avec le temps administratif
qui va au delà de 6 ans donc vous ne
pouvez pas lancer un projet impopulaire
au début mais qui est nécessaire sans
prendre non pas le risque sans avoir la
quasi-certitude d'être battu et quel est
l'homme politique qui va prendre des
décisions pour être battus
il n'existe à mon avis ni à gauche ni à
droite ni au centre ni dans le sexe
féminin ni dans sexe masculin sait on
est élu on espère être réélu c'est c'est
la logique même du système est donc le
problème c'est ce temps administratif
qui est deux amis fication des rangs
simplification de ces replis faut
s'arrêter multiplier les rapports
préalable les enquêtes les machins les
trucs les bidules c'est quand on prend
une décision agissons et pendant ce
temps là le reste du monde avance et il
avance plus vite que nous donc ça nous
amène à faire du sur place et on ne peut
pas se plaindre d'avoir une croissance
insuffisante on peut pas se plaindre de
voir l'émergence de la pauvreté
sans bien comprendre que c'est d'abord
ce surplace cette paralysie de la france
qui est qui est en cause donc je suis
parfois un peu là je lave ou de devoir
c'est
ses fils
qui qui nous embobiner qui nous
empêchent d'avancer au service de
l'intérêt général au service de nos
concitoyens c'est beaucoup merci à vous
[Musique]